uh let's see oh you know who's on hold
Jimmy from Philly the angry gardener or
landscaper who leaves like ten voice
mails and I it is on the phone I'm
curious what's maybe he can explain to
us what he's doing Jimmy what's going on
David can you hear me we can hear you
fine yeah okay now my question is
pertaining to the voicemail I left
regarding Natalie with hold on you left
like three voicemails which so no no no
you know what voice my left I left you
one voice well regarding that we went
and I think we said remind me what you
said in it okay I'm gonna remind you
right now I basically said that this is
a man masquerading as a woman oh right
okay you said my voicemail you said it
was disgusting it was let me tell whoa
Jimmy let me just remind my audience I
interviewed Natalie win last week about
fascism and authoritarianism from the
Contra points YouTube channel which is
an excellent YouTube channel and Jimmy
left a message saying that it was a
someone masquerading as a woman who's
actually a man he was focused very much
on genitalia I guess during the
interview I didn't see any genitalia my
eyes saw a man and my ears heard of me
okay so how is that disgusting for me to
make that true observation I don't see
how that's disgusting now the card you
pour made a couple leery remarks but I
did not I did not I don't support
delusion Jimmy are all of your calls
about previous calls or did you have
anything to discuss today not really you
didn't okay let me ask you something
just since I have you on the phone when
gonna call in like five times in a row
near midnight Eastern Time are probably
drinking David you have been drinking
you said probably you have and do you
drink a lot yeah you don't but you drink
enough to call reasons in a row
I was probably pissed off at you over
something yeah did you find that the
drinking makes you angry is that a
regular thing that happens no it just
makes me a little more loose-lipped
and hot like whoa Joe do you drinking it
now let me call pac-man again I called
twice shy what the hell let's make it
three times and and what are you usually
drinking I drink a beer add of Ellen
tale called
absolutely it's 11.5% and how many of
those are you throwing back in one night
when you call me five times four for
alleged equivalence okay for them is
equivalent to about nine twelve hours
Budweiser and and I just out of
curiosity if you don't mind how much do
you weigh
Oh me I weigh about 150 five-on-five
seven I'm not a big guy that's so you're
my size that's a lot of drinking if I
had four eleven and a half percent or I
would divide it over five or six hours
it's not that big
well the phone lines say different Jimmy
I'm worried about your drinking I'm not
going to lie no way mate II didn't you
never answer my question
once again you you managed to avoid my
question which is what again is what I
was what I said disgusting I don't think
a David I mean you don't really have a
leg to stand on yeah no Jimmy look I'm
making it I'll tell you why it's
disgusting if you'll allow me okay I do
hours of research to speak to an expert
about fascism and authoritarianism I do
the in you gotta allow you gotta allow
me to give you answer though alright
just let me get a question in there for
you you will get a chance to follow up I
spend hours preparing a segment that I
think is going to be a good one with
someone who has academic knowledge of
fascism and authoritarianism and
philosophy I do the interview I
broadcast that interview to my audience
and it's really important stuff and you
call in maybe after drinking for 11 and
a half percent beers and in a vitriolic
and toxic way talk about how you think
it's a the the real issue is that you've
identified that you believe this is a
man masquerading as a woman it's
disgusting and it has no bearing on the
content whatsoever it's what we call ad
hominem no David because let me show you
my experience with you okay I tuned in
yeah and visually I see I'm like oh [ __ ]
that's a training but I'm open-minded
then as soon as she starts talking I
confirm it's a trainee and I think it's
hilarious David and I can't take these
people seriously David you're gonna
masquerade as a woman I mean seriously
Jimmy if it's so funny why did you call
in angry instead of us if you had seen
something it's angry I was laughing
David he's a play to cape again I was
laughing at well it was hilarious
all right but David here's my real
question
Oh what kind of dish why you got to
discuss what was it dick dick that he
covered
that's enough Jimmy okay Jimmy's Jimmy's
uh just he just likes misgendering
people who you know it's boring it's
boring we're beyond that okay
we'll take a quick break don't hang up
if you're holding because I'm taking
more calls after the break 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 don't hang up don't hang up don't
hang up